Andrea R. Buonasera.
Grazie.
Allora, questa se Dio vuole è l'ultima.
Ce ne sarebbero tante altre di rivolte popolari del Medioevo, ma magari l'anno prossimo.
Per quest'anno questa è l'ultima e non è la meno interessante, come vedrete.
Ufficialmente si chiama la rivolta dei contadini inglesi.
La storiografia inglese l'ha sempre chiamata così, the peasants' revolt.
In realtà, come scoprirete subito, non è affatto una rivolta soltanto dei contadini.
È una rivolta di massa che coinvolge gran parte della popolazione inglese.
Non è il mio telefonino che state dicendo, vero?
Allora, per chi di voi c'era ieri e ha sentito raccontare le complicazioni della politica fiorentina,
adesso torniamo in un paese medievale più normale.
Siamo in Inghilterra, in un regno appunto dove il grosso della gente, se Dio vuole, sta in campagna,
dove c'è un'unica città che conta qualcosa, Londra, poi tante piccole cittadine con i loro gruppetti di mercanti,
ma insomma è un grande paese rurale.
È un mondo di contadini, di cavalieri, di preti, di monaci.
Ci sono ricchissimi monasteri dell'Inghilterra medievale,
che poi Enrico VIII privatizzerà quando farà la riforma, ma questa è un'altra storia.
E allora, in questo mondo di contadini, di cavalieri, di monaci,
a un certo punto comincia a crescere fra la gente comune il malessere.
Siamo nella primavera del 1381, nel maggio del 1381.
Per chi c'era ieri, sono passati tre anni dalla rivolta dei cionpi di Firenze.
Non che a loro in Inghilterra gliene importi qualcosa,
neanche ne avranno sentito parlare della rivolta dei cionpi.
Però nell'aria evidentemente c'è qualcosa.
In Inghilterra comincia tutto con, cosa non vi stupirà,
una protesta contro le tasse.
È stata appena riscossa una tassa, un poll tax, come dicono loro, un testatico.
Cos'è il testatico?
È la tassa più odiosa di tutte, la più ingiusta di tutte.
Pagano tutti uguale, il paradosso.
Pagano tutti uguale e proprio per questo è ingiusta.
Perché il Parlamento ha concesso al re di riscuotere due scellini da ogni uomo sposato
e uno scellino da chi non è sposato.
E se tu sei un lord, quei due scellini per te non sono niente.
E se invece sei un contadino, quei due scellini evidentemente pesano.
La poll tax è la tassa più facile da riscuotere, ma è anche la più ingiusta.
È quella che fa più arrabbiare la gente.
Chi ha la mia età forse si ricorderà vagamente che tanti anni fa
la signora Thatcher, primo ministro inglese, si mise nei guai
perché le venne in mente, da buon primo ministro di estrema destra,
di reintrodurre la poll tax in Inghilterra.
La poll tax è stata concessa dal Parlamento.
L'Inghilterra, ma non solo l'Inghilterra,
qualunque regno della fine del Medioevo funziona in questo modo.
E questa è la prima cosa su cui dobbiamo fermarci
perché magari non è così ovvio a tutti
che in questo mondo medievale ci fosse il Parlamento.
Cos'è il Parlamento?
L'idea di fondo è questa.
Il re può fare tante cose,
ma non può imporre delle tasse
senza il consenso del paese.
Il potere di un re medievale non è un potere assoluto.
C'è una cosa in particolare che la gente difende gelosamente
ed è il fatto
io non pago se un organismo che in un modo o nell'altro
rappresenta il paese
non ha dato il suo consenso.
Detto fra parentesi, così ci capiamo meglio.
Avete presente che più tardi si parlerà di monarchia assoluta,
di sovrani assoluti,
il re sole.
Perché sono assoluti quei sovrani del 600, del 700?
Perché possono mettere tutte le tasse che vogliono
senza chiedere il permesso a nessuno.
Un re del Medioevo non può farlo.
Un re del Medioevo deve riunire un'assemblea
in cui sono rappresentati i nobili, i baroni,
in cui è rappresentato il clero, i vescovi, gli abati,
in cui sono rappresentati i mercanti delle città
e a questa assemblea il re deve chiedere il permesso.
In Inghilterra, queste assemblee ci sono dappertutto,
l'Inghilterra è più moderna degli altri paesi
nel senso che la chiama già il Parlamento, questa assemblea.
E la cosa non vi tornerà così strana,
quando il re riunisce il Parlamento nell'Inghilterra medievale,
lo riunisce diviso in due camere.
La Camera dei Lord, dove siedono i baroni e i vescovi,
e la Camera dei Comuni, dove sono rappresentati i mercanti delle città
e in generale il popolo, ma di fatto sono solo i mercanti delle città.
L'unica differenza rispetto ad esso è che adesso la Camera dei Lord
non conta più niente e fanno tutto i comuni.
Noi racconteremo di un'epoca in cui i comuni venivano consultati anche loro,
ma chi davvero comandava era la Camera dei Lord, naturalmente.
Allora, il paese è rappresentato,
però la maggioranza degli abitanti, i contadini,
si devono fidare che i loro signori si preoccupino un pochino in Parlamento
di rappresentare i loro interessi,
perché mentre i mercanti di Londra mandano un gruppetto dei loro al Parlamento,
i contadini sanno che c'è andato un rappresentante dei monaci del monastero,
o c'è andato il Lord.
Ecco, speriamo che tenga conto che anche noi non vogliamo pagare troppo,
ma i contadini direttamente non sono rappresentati.
E dunque questa poll tax è stata riscossa
e c'è grande scontento nel paese.
Un cronista, sapete che tutte le cose che io vi racconto
è perché ci sono dei cronisti dell'epoca che le hanno raccontate,
che hanno vissuto queste cose, che le hanno viste succedere,
e poi si sono seduti e hanno scritto.
I cronisti che raccontano la grande rivolta inglese del 1381 sono tutti ostili.
Non è più come nella Firenze dei Ciompi, dove vi ricordate ieri chi c'era?
Qualche autore che tutto sommato stava con i ribelli c'era.
Qui no, i cronisti sono quasi tutti monaci o nobili,
e sono contrari alla rivolta che racconteremo.
Ma in genere hanno l'onestà di dire quali erano le ragioni dei ribelli.
E il punto di partenza è questo.
Sono appena stati riscossi, dice un cronista,
dei sussidi, li chiamavano sussidi proprio perché,
non mi sono forse spiegato bene,
quando il re ha bisogno di soldi,
deve riunire il Parlamento e dire
avrei bisogno di aiuto, dovreste darmi un aiutino.
Un sussidio è uno dei termini che si usano.
Si chiama così perché deve essere ben chiaro che è una tantum.
Se poi l'anno prossimo ti servono di nuovo dei soldi,
riunisci di nuovo il Parlamento e ci spieghi che cosa ne vuoi fare.
Erano appena stati riscossi dei sussidi eccezionalmente pesanti,
concessi con leggerezza in Parlamento
e destorti con la forza al povero popolo.
Questi sussidi non erano di alcun vantaggio al regno,
ma erano spesi male e a detrimento dei comuni.
Vedrete che nel linguaggio di questi cronisti,
che scrivono in latino,
comunia, ma sono i commons, la camera dei comuni, il popolo.
Nel linguaggio inglese i comuni già all'epoca vuol dire
tutti quelli che non sono nobili e non sono chierici.
E dunque i comuni, i contadini, gli artigiani, i mercanti, mormorano.
La gente mormora, le tasse sono state riscosse in modo spietato,
troppo, il Parlamento non doveva concederle,
non fa i nostri interessi il Parlamento,
si capisce, ci sono solo i signori in Parlamento
e per di più li sprecano questi soldi.
Il governo è corrotto, marcio, dove finiscono i soldi?
Non è colpa del re, dice la gente.
Prima di dare la colpa al re ci si mette sempre molto,
perché il re è la figura, come dire, sacrale,
un po' magica, che rappresenta tutti.
Lui è davvero il regno.
Quindi prima di dare la colpa al re ci si pensa dieci volte.
In questo caso poi il re ha 14 anni, Riccardo II.
Ovviamente non governa lui, lui non può avere colpe.
Chi governa?
E chi ha le colpe, quindi?
Il regno lo governa lo zio del re,
Giovanni, duca di Lancaster.
Lui è il colpevole se i soldi finiscono dove non dovrebbero.
Lui e gli altri ministri,
e in particolare il presidente del consiglio dei ministri,
all'epoca non si chiama così, si chiama il cancelliere,
come si chiama ancora oggi in Germania, per esempio,
il cancelliere del regno, l'arcivescovo di Canterbury.
Loro sono i colpevoli,
loro dovrebbero rispondere,
dove sono finiti i soldi?
Fin qua la gente mormora,
ma potrebbe anche finire lì.
Il problema è che anche il governo è scontento.
La tassa ha reso poco.
L'anno scorso il Parlamento aveva concesso
una tassa uguale a questa
e avevamo incassato di più.
Come mai quest'anno i soldi non sono arrivati?
Bisogna, la cosa vi stupirà,
nominare una commissione d'inchiesta.
E la commissione d'inchiesta comincia a esaminare i conti
e a fare le pulci ai finanzieri
che hanno riscosso le tasse.
Qui ci dobbiamo di nuovo fermare
per raccontare un altro aspetto meraviglioso
di come funzionava un regno del Medioevo.
Il re non dispone di funzionari a sufficienza
per riscuotere direttamente le tasse.
L'apparato burocratico è ristretto,
sono pochi i dipendenti pubblici.
Uno pensa, bello, bellissimo,
pochi i dipendenti pubblici?
No, no.
Se sono pochi i dipendenti pubblici,
quando devi riscuotere le tasse,
cosa fai?
Trovi un banchiere,
un finanziere,
un privato
che anticipa i soldi
e poi si incarica a lui di riscuotere.
Lui anticipa fino a una certa somma,
ci si mette d'accordo.
Poi il finanziere riscuote,
tutto quello che riscuote in più
viene a lui naturalmente.
E quindi il finanziere manda i suoi scagnozzi privati
a riscuotere le tasse.
Per cui la gente,
quando deve tirare fuori i soldi,
non ha neanche la soddisfazione
di mandarli direttamente al re,
ma arriva un tirapiedi di un privato
a prendere i soldi.
Le inchieste si diffondono in tutto il regno
e si comincia a dire
non sono solo i finanzieri che hanno rubato
e che hanno riscosso poco,
troppa gente non ha pagato.
In un villaggio dell'Essex,
siamo nell'Inghilterra meridionale,
le contee più vicine a Londra.
A Brentwood, nell'Essex,
arriva un commissario
sostenendo che gli abitanti
non hanno pagato abbastanza.
Anzi, non hanno proprio pagato.
Devono ripagare di nuovo la tassa.
La gente non è contenta.
Gli abitanti del villaggio si radunano in piazza.
Il commissario è lì.
Gli abitanti, un centinaio di scalmanati,
cominciano a insultarlo.
Il commissario minaccia di farli arrestare.
Loro minacciano di fargli la pelle.
Il commissario scappa da Brentwood
e corre a Londra dal governo
a lamentarsi di essere stato aggredito.
Gli abitanti di Brentwood
capiscono di averla fatta grossa.
Hanno paura che arrivi la punizione.
Cosa fanno?
Siamo nell'Inghilterra di Robin Hood.
È passato tanto tempo,
ma la mentalità della gente è ancora quella.
Dove si va? Nella foresta.
Scappiamo nella foresta,
dove tutti i fuorilegge trovano rifugio.
Stanno nella foresta un giorno,
due giorni,
tre giorni.
Non succede niente,
però sono spaventati.
A questo punto cominciano a dire,
visto che siamo in ballo noi,
cerchiamo di convincere anche gli altri villaggi
a fare resistenza contro le tasse,
a insorgere.
Proprio in quel momento arriva lì
un giudice del re
mandato a indagare su quello che sta succedendo.
Cos'è questa insurrezione?
Cos'è che avete minacciato
il commissario del fisco?
Ecco,
che succede in questo posto?
Il giudice comincia a istruire un processo.
Istruire un processo vuol dire
reclutare una giuria.
E' una delle garanzie della Magna Carta.
Ogni uomo libero ha diritto
a essere giudicato da una giuria
di suoi pari.
Bellissima cosa.
Ma quando un giudice del re
deve riunire una giuria,
chi viene nella giuria?
I ricchi del posto,
i notabili,
le persone influenti,
quelli che hanno studiato,
c'è sempre qualche avvocato,
qualche laureato,
quelli vanno in giuria.
Dal punto di vista del contadino
non sono i miei pari.
Sono sempre i signori
che vanno in giuria.
E a questo punto,
quando il giudice del re,
Sir Robert Belknap,
sta radunando la giuria
per giudicare i colpevoli
di questa prima insurrezione,
la folla lo aggredisce.
Aggrediscono il giudice,
lo acchiappano,
accusandolo di tradimento
contro il re e il regno.
Questa è una cosa,
me la brucio fin da ora,
nella testa di quelli
che stanno insorgendo
e che poi insorgeranno
sempre più numerosi,
e chi c'era ieri
e l'altro ieri
sa che è sempre così
in queste rivolte medievali,
loro, i ribelli,
non stanno facendo niente
di illegale,
stanno ristabilendo
la giustizia.
I traditori sono gli altri,
il governo,
i giudici,
i nobili,
loro sono i traditori.
E noi ristabiliamo
la giustizia
secondo la legge.
Quindi la folla
accusa il giudice del re
di essere un traditore.
Lo prendono
e lo costringono
a giurare sulla Bibbia
che non condurrà mai più
inchieste come quella
contro la brava gente
che si è ribellata
contro un'ingiustizia.
E fin qui va ancora bene,
poi però vogliono sapere
dal giudice
chi aveva accettato
di sedere nella tua giuria
vogliamo i nomi.
E il giudice fa i nomi
e la folla va a casa
dei giurati,
li prende,
li trascina fuori
e li decapita
e brucia le loro case.
Anche qui,
attenzione,
decapitare qualcuno
e distruggere
i suoi possedimenti
è quello
che la giustizia del re
fa ai traditori
e la pena
per il tradimento.
Quello che la gente sente
è
questi
che accettavano
di fare
e di mettere in piedi
questi processi
sono dei traditori.
Noi siamo invece
dalla parte
della giustizia,
della legalità
e del re
che poverino
ha 14 anni
e non sa
di essere circondato
di traditori.
A questo punto
l'insurrazione
dilaga
e prende
di mira
vabbè
tanto vale
che vi legga
il cronista
si proponevano
di uccidere
tutti gli
avvocati
giurati
e funzionari
del re
che potessero
trovare
tutti i traditori
lo stato
la giustizia
tutto un sistema
marcio
corrotto
ai danni
del popolo
ovviamente
tutti i nobili
notabili
e la gente
che ha studiato
scappa dall'essex
e rapidamente
però l'insurrazione
dilaga
anche nelle contee
vicine
gli insorti
scrivono
agli altri villaggi
anche voi
dovete ribellarvi
e l'insurrazione
dilaga
gli apprendisti
lasciavano
i loro padroni
per unirsi
ai ribelli
anche qui
c'è tutto un mondo
intanto
non sono solo
contadini
gli apprendisti
sono quelli
che stanno
a bottega
dal fabbro
dal tessitore
dal bottaio
dal sellaio
ecco
quelli
sono gli apprendisti
sono artigiani
e naturalmente
gli apprendisti
sono i giovani
che scappano
mollano il lavoro
la bottega
per andare
a unirsi
a questa cosa
fantastica
che sta succedendo
sono sempre
in avanguardia
i cronisti
che raccontano
questa cosa
benché siano
orripilati
da quello
che stanno raccontando
però
ci danno
una serie
di dettagli
che fanno vedere
con la massima chiarezza
appunto
l'estrema lucidità
di questi ribelli
e la loro certezza
che loro
non si stanno
ribellando
contro il regno
anzi
loro sono
il regno
per esempio
la gente
scappa dai villaggi
per unirsi
alla folla
dei ribelli
a un certo punto
viene fatta un'ordinanza
quelli che abitano
nei villaggi costieri
devono stare a casa
e non venire
a unirsi
alla ribellione
perché
perché c'è la guerra
c'è sempre la guerra
dei cent'anni
che non finisce mai
naturalmente
e ci sono i francesi
dall'altra parte
della manica
i villaggi costieri
sono continuamente
minacciati
e noi
noi non ci prendiamo
la responsabilità
di allontanare
gli uomini validi
dalle coste
il regno
è in guerra
e noi
i ribelli
ce ne facciamo carico
e noi decidiamo
che i ribelli
che vivono
lungo le coste
restano lì
per continuare
a difendere
il regno
dai maledetti
francesi
e poi
dice un cronista
e dicevano
che c'era
più di un re
e che loro
avrebbero accettato
e obbedito
un solo re
re Riccardo
perché
più di un re
il reggente
Giovanni
duca di Lancaster
odiatissimo
zio del re
ha sposato
l'erede
del regno
di Castiglia
e sostiene
di essere lui
il vero titolare
del regno
di Castiglia
quindi si firma
re di Castiglia
questa cosa
ai buoni sudditi
inglesi
non piace per niente
due re nel regno
non li vogliamo
solo uno
il vero re
re Riccardo
e ancora
i cronisti
che scrivono
tutti in latino
sono quasi tutti monaci
i cronisti
che scrivono
in latino
dicono
e avevano
una parola
d'ordine
in inglese
e a questo punto
i cronisti
riferiscono
in inglese
inglese di fine
qual era
la parola
d'ordine
dei ribelli
con chi stai
letteralmente
con chi tieni
e la risposta
era
with king richard
con re Riccardo
and with
the true
commons
e con i fedeli
comuni
e chi non sapeva
o non voleva
rispondere
così
veniva
decapitato
dilagano in tutta
l'inghilterra
meridionale
arrivano a
canterbury
è il grande
santuario
la sede del
pellegrinaggio
più importante
d'inghilterra
ricordate
chosser
i racconti
di canterbury
grande capolavoro
della letteratura
inglese medievale
scritto
in quegli anni
che racconta
proprio un
pellegrinaggio
a canterbury
tutti vanno
i ribelli
bloccano
tutte le strade
che vanno
a canterbury
e fermavano
tutti i pellegrini
di qualunque
condizione
anche i signori
e li facevano
giurare
e i pellegrini
fermati dai
ribelli
dovevano giurare
primo
di essere fedeli
a re riccardo
e ai comuni
secondo
questo è bellissimo
che non avrebbero
accettato
nessun re
che si chiamasse
giovanni
il duca di lancaster
si chiama giovanni
però qui
c'è anche
qualcos'altro
perché tutti loro
da bambini
hanno sentito
le storie
del buon re riccardo
e del cattivo
re giovanni
avete presente
no il cattivo re giovanni
ecco
allora
un re in inghilterra
non può chiamarsi giovanni
inutile
il primo re giovanni
ha rovinato la piazza
per sempre
e il duca di lancaster
con quel nome
non ha speranze
e ancora
i pellegrini
che vanno a canterbury
quando vengono fermati
dai posti di blocco
devono giurare
che quando saranno
tornati ai loro villaggi
li inciteranno
a ribellarsi
e che non avrebbero
accettato
nessuna
tassa
riscossa
nel regno
tranne quelle
che i loro padri
e antenati
avevano conosciuto
e accettato
dove c'è
appunto
fortissima
l'idea
che io pago le tasse
perché accetto
di pagarle
la teoria
è che mi rappresenta
il Parlamento
ma se decido
che il Parlamento
non mi rappresenta
decido io
che tasse
sono disposto a pagare
e quali tasse
questo è l'altro aspetto
fondamentale
della mentalità
medievale
quello che hanno accettato
i miei padri
sono tenuto
ad accettarlo
anch'io
non sarebbe giusto
ma nessuno
mi può costringere
a aggiungere qualcosa
nessuno
può cambiare
le leggi
a mio danno
che c'erano
al tempo
di mio padre
io ho il diritto
che continuino
anche adesso
e dunque
invadono
Canterbury
e grida
l'arcivescovo
non è lì
capo del governo
è col re
ma loro
invadono
Canterbury
e gridano
ai monaci
che adesso
devono eleggere
un nuovo
arcivescovo
che scelgano
pure uno
fra loro
fra i monaci
ma che
eleggano
un nuovo
arcivescovo
perché l'arcivescovo
che c'è adesso
è un traditore
e sarà
decapitato
per la sua
malvagità
e il cronista
che racconta
questo
annota
fra parentesi
e lo fu
davvero
entro cinque
giorni
saccheggiano
il palazzo
dell'arcivescovo
ovviamente il palazzo
è pieno di ricchezze
vedi
la prova
che il governo
ruba
adesso lo andremo a prendere
l'arcivescovo
e lo costringeremo
a rendere conto
di come ha usato
i nostri soldi
e la gente
della cittadina
di Canterbury
è tutta con loro
dopodiché
in quel momento
di colpo
l'insurrezione
si complica
con una nuova
rivendicazione
ci spostiamo
finora erano le tasse
e la corruzione
del governo
adesso di colpo
entra in campo
un altro aspetto
che per gran parte
dei contadini
dell'Inghilterra
è una cosa
importantissima
la servitù
in Inghilterra
vige
la servitù
non dovete
immaginare
la servitù
della gleba
in modo folcloristico
come qualcosa
appunto
che sono
gli usprimen octis
o altre robe
del genere
è una cosa
molto tecnica
semplicemente
moltissimi contadini
non tutti
hanno degli obblighi
ereditari
per cui
devono fare
dei lavori
gratis
per i loro signori
questo lo spiega
molto bene
un cronista francese
il quale racconta
questa cosa
e dovendola raccontare
al suo pubblico
francese
in Francia
i servi
sono pochissimi
dovendola raccontare
al suo pubblico
francese
il cronista
Françard
descrive
perfettamente
questa situazione
c'è un'usanza
in Inghilterra
che i nobili
hanno grande libertà
sui plebei
e li tengono
in servaggio
cioè
gli affittuari
devono
arare
le terre
del signore
mietere
e immagazzinare
il suo grano
e trebbiarlo
e per obbligo
tagliare
il suo fieno
e la sua legna
e portarglieli
a casa
gratis
si intende
e tutte queste cose
le devono fare
perché sono servi
e c'è più di questa gente
in Inghilterra
che in ogni altro regno
allora
caso vuole
che proprio nel momento
in cui
i commons
stanno ribellandosi
in tutta l'Inghilterra
meridionale
in una cittadina
del Kent
a Gravesand
un cavaliere
Sir Simon
sta facendo
causa
a un abitante
di quella cittadina
sostenendo
che è un suo servo
e perciò
dovrebbe essere
a casa
al villaggio
a lavorare
per lui
e invece
se ne è andato
senza permesso
in città
e quindi
adesso lui
lo rivuole
le autorità
di questa cittadina
chiedono al cavaliere
se si può
mettersi d'accordo
adesso
quest'uomo
vive qui da noi
è diventato
un abitante
di Gravesand
noi vorremmo
vedere se si può
liberarlo
Sir Simon
chiede una somma
enorme
300 sterline
al cambio
grosso modo
100.000 euro
una somma
che avrebbe rovinato
il povero uomo
gli abitanti
sindaco in testa
chiedono
al nobile cavaliere
se per piacere
potrebbe moderare
le condizioni
dicendo che
l'uomo
era un cristiano
e di buona reputazione
e che non era giusto
che fosse rovinato
per sempre
al che
il detto
Sir Simon
si adirò
disprezzando
molto
questi bravi
cittadini
e per la sua
alterigia
ordinò
ai due
sergenti del re
che lo accompagnavano
di legare
quest'uomo
e incarcerarlo
capite come funziona
se tu sei un nobile
cavaliere
e fai causa
a un poveraccio
automaticamente
hai già alcuni
poliziotti
che ti accompagnano
ecco perché siete già
per scontato
che comunque
probabilmente hai ragione
tu
i sergenti del re
sono i poliziotti
infatti
dunque Sir Simon
fa arrestare
quest'uomo
e i comuni
cominciarono
ad agitarsi
e a questo punto
come un incendio
fra le folle
dei ribelli
che sono già lì
che battono il paese
a caccia di avvocati
fra le folle
dei ribelli
comincia a correre
questa voce
adesso c'è anche
un'altra cosa
adesso vogliamo
anche farla finita
con la servitù
e i cronisti
sono straordinariamente
attenti
i cronisti
ripeto
sono monaci
sono gente
intelligente
e colta
sono contentissimi
che la rivolta
sia fallita
però
sono capaci
di capire
esattamente
come ragionava
questa gente
e di ripetere
i loro discorsi
questa gente
infelice
cominciò a sollevarsi
perché dicevano
che erano tenuti
in grande servitù
e all'inizio
del mondo
dicevano
non c'erano servi
perciò dicevano
che nessuno
dovrebbe essere
servo
e non capivano
perché dovevano
essere sottomessi
come bestie
e dissero
che non l'avrebbero
più sopportato
perché volevano
essere tutti uguali
e se aravano
o facevano qualcosa
per il loro signore
volevano essere
pagati
come gli altri
come vedete
appunto
la sostanza
poi è quella
c'è gente
che ha degli obblighi
per cui deve
lavorare gratis
e questo
non va bene
vogliamo essere
tutti uguali
ora
se queste idee
si diffondono
in un attimo
fra la folla
dei ribelli
è perché
covavano
già da tempo
in Inghilterra
la gente
mormorava
e protestava
che la servitù
era una cosa
ingiusta
e se lo facevano
e lo facevano
anche apertamente
è perché c'erano
anche dei preti
dei parroci
che a messa
gli dicevano
queste stesse cose
e cioè
che la servitù
è ingiusta
e che bisognerebbe
ribellarsi
un parroco
in particolare
molto famoso
che in quel momento
di colpo
diventa uno
degli idoli
dei ribelli
ma che già da molto tempo
aveva molta influenza
si chiamava
John Ball
Sir John Ball
come dicevano loro
che davano del Sir
sia ai cavalieri
sia ai preti
allora
Sir John Ball
ovvero
come riferisce
un monaco
e queste idee
le aveva
un prete
matto
nella contea
di Kent
chiamato
John Ball
che per le sue
folli prediche
era stato
imprigionato
tre volte
dall'arcivescovo
di Canterbury
perché questo è un prete
e l'arcivescovo
una volta lo chiama
mi risulta
che tu dici
non farlo più
poi arrivano di nuovo
i rapporti
quello continua
lo chiami di nuovo
guarda che ti tolgo
la parrocchia
ti tolgo la parrocchia
ti proibisco di predicare
e quello continua
cosa fai
lo imprigioni
tre mesi
nel tuo castello
di Canterbury
e poi gli dici
adesso vai
e non peccare più
e quello
ogni volta
ricomincia
e cosa raccontava
ai suoi fedeli
John Ball
le cose
non vanno bene
in Inghilterra
e non miglioreranno
finché tutto
non sarà
comune
e non ci saranno
più villani
né gentiluomini
ma che siamo
tutti uniti
e i signori
non siano
più padroni
insomma
era un comunista
fondamentalmente
John Ball
era un prete
avrebbe dovuto
solidarizzare
con i signori
ma si vede
che era un prete
figlio di contadini
nelle sue prediche
quando diceva
noi
intendeva noi
la povera gente
e loro
i ricchi
loro si vestono
di velluti
e pellicce
e noi
di tessuti
da poco
loro hanno
i loro vini
spezie
e pane bianco
noi abbiamo
gli avanzi
e beviamo acqua
cosa orrenda
nel medio
di essere ridotti
a bere acqua
è proprio
il massimo
della deprivazione
e dell'angoscia
loro se ne stanno
nelle loro belle
case
e noi fuori
a lavorare
al vento
e alla pioggia
e coi frutti
della nostra fatica
mantengono
la loro bella vita
ci chiamano
servi
e se non siamo
pronti a obbedire
ci bastonano
andiamo dal re
è giovane
mostriamogli
la servitù
in cui siamo tenuti
e facciamogli
capire
che deve cambiare
così diceva
John Ball
la domenica
quando la gente
usciva
dalle chiese
nei villaggi
e perciò
molti dei plebei
lo amavano
e così
mormoravano
fra loro
nei campi
e per la strada
dicendo che
John Ball
diceva la verità
e dunque
quando i ribelli
decidono
di intraprendere
questa crociata
contro la servitù
vanno a cercare
John Ball
dove è John Ball
nelle prigioni
dell'arcivescovo
e andiamo
e lo liberiamo
e faremo
arcivescovo
lui
e quando fu
liberato
predicò
un sermone
che cominciava
così
quando Adamo
zappava
e Eva
filava
chi era
allora
un gentiluomo
e cercò
di provare
che tutti
gli uomini
sono creati
uguali
dalla natura
nota bene
bisogna stare
attenti
che tutti
gli uomini
sono creati
uguali
dalla natura
è una verità
ovvia che
qualunque
intellettuale del
medioevo
avrebbe riconosciuto
è ovvio
ed evidente
tutti gli uomini
sono creati
uguali
non c'è il minimo
dubbio
sul piano
teorico
è così
e davanti a Dio
nessuno mai
nel medioevo
si sarebbe sognato
di pensarla
diversamente
tutt'altra cosa
è dire
ah ma allora
la servitù
i ricchi
cosa c'entra
quello non c'entra
siamo creati
uguali
poi quello che è successo
con la storia umana
quella è colpa
nostra
mentre invece
pretendere
coerentemente
di dire
se siamo creati
tutti uguali
vogliamo essere
uguali anche
nella vita vera
allora
lì
è la cosa
su cui non erano
più tutti d'accordo
anzi
John Ball
invece
voleva arrivare
a quello
e che se Dio
avesse voluto
creare i servi
sicuramente
fin dall'inizio
avrebbe stabilito
chi era servo
e chi signore
e un cronista
uno dei più ostili
a John Ball
conclude
era guardato
dai comuni
come un profeta
ebbe poi
la sua ricompensa
quando fu
trascinato
sbudellato
impiccato
e decapitato
come traditore
ma nel frattempo
la rivolta
di Laga
e l'abolizione
della servitù
diventa la prima
delle richieste
vennero a Londra
a parlare col re
per essere resi liberi
perché non volevano
servi in Inghilterra
dove di nuovo
notate
questi sono tutti
i cronisti ostili
che non hanno
nessun interesse
a esagerare
la coerenza
e la chiarezza
di queste richieste
e invece
tutti lo dicono
avevano una richiesta
chiarissima
e non era
io voglio essere libero
era
tutti devono essere liberi
dove
nello spazio
che è il nostro
il regno
di Inghilterra
noi siamo il popolo
e non vogliamo più
che nel regno
di Inghilterra
ci siano dei servi
a questo punto
i ribelli
marciano su Londra
il 12 giugno
sono a Blackheath
è un quartiere
di Londra
oggi
a sud del Tamigi
dove c'è
l'osservatorio di Greenwich
all'epoca
è un villaggio
Londra all'epoca
è piccolissima
corrisponde
alla city
di oggi
che non per niente
si chiama la city
perché la città
era quello
in origine
dunque i ribelli
sono a pochi chilometri
da Londra
e nessuno
li può fermare
il duca di Lancaster
reggente del regno
è alla frontiera
scozzese
lontanissimo
c'è il re
con i suoi consiglieri
e il re
manda ai ribelli
un cavaliere
per chiedere
che cosa vogliono
e per che motivo
si sono mossi
risposero
che erano insorti
per salvarlo
il re
e per distruggere
chi tradiva
lui
e il regno
il re
gli risponde
chiedendo
di fermarsi
e promettendo
che verrà
a parlare
con loro
e ad ascoltare
le loro richieste
gli insorti
gli dicono
benissimo
noi siamo qui
a Black Hills
ti aspettiamo
qui domattina
il re
promette
di venire
riunisce
il suo consiglio
nella torre di Londra
presieduto
dall'arcivescovo
discutono
cosa fare
l'unica
è andare a sentire
cosa vogliono
il 13 giugno
al mattino
il re
sente messa
nella torre di Londra
che è la fortezza
naturalmente
la torre è la fortezza
con cui il re
controlla
la città di Londra
e dove lui
si difende
da qualunque minaccia
il re sente messa
nella torre
poi si imbarca
su una barca
sul Tamigi
insieme all'arcivescovo
al tesoriere
i principali ministri
e comincia a scendere
il Tamigi
per andare incontro
ai ribelli
man mano
che vanno giù
sulle rive
c'è una folla
sempre più numerosa
che acclama
urla
dopo un po'
si prendono paura
sulla barca
si fermano
e discutono
cosa fare
decidono
che è troppo rischioso
attraccare
meglio tornare indietro
i ribelli
quando vedono
che torna indietro
si infuriano
e gli mandano
una delegazione
le nostre richieste
vogliamo
la testa
del duca di Lancaster
dell'arcivescovo
la testa
del tesoriere
segue elenco
di 15 ministri
di cui i ribelli
vogliono la testa
nome e cognome
il re
risponde
di no
torna a Londra
in barca
si chiude
nella torre
con i suoi consiglieri
e a questo punto
i ribelli
marciano davvero
su Londra
arrivano
al ponte
di Londra
unica via
d'accesso
attraverso
il Tamigi
il ponte
di Londra
all'epoca
è un ponte
elevatoio
il sindaco
di Londra
lo ha fatto
alzare
ma il popolo
di Londra
tumultua
e pretende
che il ponte
sia abbassato
e i ribelli
fatti entrare
perché
non lasciamo
entrare
questa buona
gente
in città
sono i nostri
compagni
e quello
che fanno
lo fanno
per noi
i ribelli
garantiscono
che se entrano
in città
non saccheggeranno
non commetteranno
violenze
e tutto quello
che prendono
lo pagheranno
la folla
obbliga il sindaco
a aprire le porte
e calare il ponte
i ribelli
entrano
tavoli in strada
e da mangiare
per tutti
dopodiché
i ribelli
mantengono la parola
nessuna violenza
il problema
è che i londinesi
cominciano le violenze
la folla
di Londra
dà l'assalto
al Savoy
il palazzo
del duca
di Lancaster
è il più ricco
palazzo
di Londra
da poco costruito
pieno di ogni
sorta di ricchezze
la folla
dà l'assalto
al Savoy
lo devasta
da cima
a fondo
e lo brucia
e lo rade
alle fondamenta
qualche cronista
ostile
dice sì
chissà quanti
sono morti
ubriachi
nelle cantine
del Savoy
dove il duca
di Lancaster
aveva i suoi
vini francesi
naturalmente
e i cronisti
più onesti
dicono
non hanno
saccheggiato
niente
anzi avevano
dichiarato
che se qualcuno
saccheggiava
lo avrebbero impiccato
noi non siamo
dei ladri
le ricchezze
del Savoy
tutti gli oggetti
preziosi
sono stati distrutti
e buttati
nel tamigi
i tessuti preziosi
stracciati
le pietre preziose
le perle
pestate
nei mortai
poi hanno trovato
l'abito di gala
del duca
di Lancaster
l'hanno montato
su un manichino
e gli hanno tirato
con l'arco
al bersaglio
dopodiché
procedono
a incendiare
le case
dei ministri
dei giudici
dei funzionari
del re
tutte le prigioni
vengono aperte
e molta gente
viene decapitata
appunto
funzionari
uomini di legge
avvocati
tutti quelli
che riescono
a acchiappare
sono trascinati fuori
anche dalle chiese
e decapitati
i cronisti
notano
i ribelli
non uccidevano
mai nessuno
se non
per decapitazione
di nuovo
è la forma
legale
di esecuzione
dei traditori
noi non siamo
una marmaglia
senza legge
che lincia la gente
noi siamo
il popolo
del regno
che fa giustizia
secondo la legge
e il re
è assediato
nella torre
e la folla
fuori grida
vogliamo parlare
col re
e il re
quattordicenne
fa bandire
dalle finestre
che se vogliono
parlare con lui
si trovino tutti
domani mattina
a Mile End
che è un grande
pratone fuori
Londra
all'epoca
dove i bravi
londinesi
la domenica
andavano a spasso
lì c'è spazio
per tutti
ci sono centomila
ribelli dentro Londra
in questo momento
secondo i cronisti
il re fa anche dire
che se tornano
alle loro case
li perdonerà
i ribelli
rispondono
che non torneranno
a casa
finché non avranno
catturato i traditori
e ottenuto
l'abolizione
della servitù
il re è lì
nella torre
con i suoi consiglieri
dalla torre
vedono bruciare
le loro stesse case
i ministri
vedono bruciare
le loro case
la folla è fuori
a perdita d'occhio
non c'è niente da fare
bisogna andarci
o meglio
l'arcivescovo
cerca di svignarsela
di Canterbury
a un bel momento
esce da una porticina
sul Tamigi
per prendere una barca
e scappare
lo vede una lavandaia
comincia a gridare
a corre gente
l'arcivescovo
è costretto
a tornare dentro
il giorno dopo
venerdì
14 giugno
alle 7 del mattino
il re è
a Mile End
davanti ai ribelli
accompagnato
dai suoi cavalieri
tutti quelli che ha
non molti
i ribelli
sono lì in massa
e all'arrivo del re
si inginocchiano
davanti a lui
e il capo
dei ribelli
perché c'è un capo
salta fuori
a questo punto
si chiama
Watt Tyler
Tyler
è uno di quei cognomi
che indicano il mestiere
è un fabbricante di tegole
è uno che fabbrica
tegole e mattoni
un artigiano
ancora una volta
Watt Tyler
si presenta
davanti al re
ha una bandiera
di San Giorgio
il protettore
del regno
l'insegna ufficiale
Watt Tyler
si presenta
davanti al re
e lo prega
di permettere
che facciano
giustizia
dei traditori
e lo prega
di concedere
che d'ora in poi
nessuno sia più servo
o debba lavorare gratis
in Inghilterra
e il re
davanti ai ribelli
fa proclamare
che tutte le loro richieste
sono accettate
e a questo punto
si torna a Londra
e i ribelli dietro
e il re
torna nella torre
e i ribelli
invadono la torre
qui i cronisti
ovviamente
si divertono
a descrivere
questa marmaglia
che entra
nelle stanze del re
tira la barba
ai suoi cavalieri
si siedono sul letto
del re
c'è la regina madre
con il re
entrano nei suoi appartamenti
uno le dice
dammi un bacio
bella
ecco
dopodiché
ci sono anche
molti soldati
fanno causa comune
con i ribelli
nessuno li ferma
l'arcivescovo
è nella cappella
che aspetta
l'arcivescovo
sa benissimo
cosa sta per succedere
quel mattino
all'alba
ha cantato messa
si è confessato
ha confessato
tutti gli altri
e poi
nell'attesa
ha fatto dire
altre messe
una messa
dopo l'altra
anche lui partecipa
canta le litanie
durante una di queste messe
mentre sta cantando
le litanie
quando arriva
alle parole
omnes sancti
orate
pronobis
tutti i santi
pregate per noi
la folla
entra
e lo trascina
fuori
fuori ci sono
centomila persone
che lo aspettano
è un enorme urlo
lo trascinano fuori
insieme a quattro ministri
e li decapitano
poi la testa
dell'arcivescovo
viene portata
ed gli altri ministri
vengono portati
in processione
infisse su lance
fino all'abbazia
di Westminster
per far ben vedere
a tutti
che giustizia
è fatta
dei traditori
poi le portano
al ponte di Londra
e lì
sul cancello
della città
le piantano
lì in bella vista
la testa
dell'arcivescovo
in modo che si capisca
bene chi è
gli inchiodano
in testa
una mitria
rossa
in modo che si veda
che è lui
dopodiché
le cose però
scappano anche di mano
come succede
quando la violenza
rivoluzionaria
non ha più limiti
per esempio
c'è una deriva
xenofoba
Londra
è l'unico porto
importante
l'unica grande città
commerciale del regno
è piena di stranieri
è piena di mercanti
stranieri
ci sono gli italiani
i lombardi
come dicono loro
ancora oggi
nella city
c'è lombard street
ma in quell'epoca
italiani sono pochi
sono soprattutto
fiamminghi
mercanti che vengono
dalle fiandre
mercanti
banchieri
la gente li odia
come sempre
quelli sono ricchi
fanno i soldi
e a un certo punto
tra i ribelli
corre la parola d'ordine
che ha dato ordine
ha dato il permesso
di ammazzare i fiamminghi
anzi ha dato ordine
chi non si sa
però
non importa
ordine di decapitare
tutti i fiamminghi
e allora la gente comincia
la caccia allo straniero
e anche quelli
li trascinano fuori
e li decapitano
dice un cronista
circa 150
ammazzati
e si vedevano
i mucchi di cadaveri
nelle piazze
e il re
prigioniero
a tutti gli effetti
dei ribelli
comincia a produrre
quello che loro
hanno chiesto
documenti ufficiali
in cui
perdona i ribelli
per tutto quello
che eventualmente
possono aver fatto
e soprattutto
abolisce la servitù
ogni villaggio
vuole la sua
pergamena
noi veniamo
da Brentwood
vogliamo la pergamena
dove il re dice
che a Brentwood
la servitù
è abolita
e ogni villaggio
vuole la sua
e ogni contea
e il re
mette al lavoro
tutta la sua
cancelleria
30 chierici
per tutta la giornata
producono
documenti
ufficiali
di abolizione
della servitù
c'è un piccolo problema
che un documento
ufficiale
per avere valore
deve essere sigillato
col grande sigillo
reale
e controfirmato
dal detentore
ufficiale
del grande sigillo
chi è il detentore
il cancelliere
del regno
l'arcivescovo
di Canterbury
la cui testa
in questo momento
è inalberata
non c'è un cancelliere
non si possono produrre
documenti legalmente validi
i ribelli
dicono
re non starai scherzando
il re
nomina un cancelliere
per un giorno
prende uno
qualunque
lo fa cancelliere
gli consegna
il gran sigillo
a questo punto
i documenti
sono validi
e molta gente
comincia a tornare
a casa
sventolando
la pergamena
che dice
tutti i servi
sono liberi
e viene anche
concessa
una grande carta
per tutto il regno
in cui il re
dichiara
che in tutto
il regno
d'Inghilterra
tutti sono
liberi
ci sarebbero
mille cose
che succedono
ma bisognerà
saltarle un po'
perché altrimenti
tenete conto
che questo è
quel che succede
a Londra
ma in tutta
l'Inghilterra
la gente insorge
ve ne dico una
a Cambridge
dove c'è
l'università
la gente del posto
ovviamente
odia i professori
e gli studenti
i quali hanno
i loro privilegi
vivono a Cambridge
ma non hanno
nessun obbligo
verso il comune
non pagano
le tasse comunali
non obbediscono
al sindaco
quindi la rivoluzione
a Cambridge
si traduce in questo
che la gente
dà l'assalto
all'università
col sindaco
in testa
dando l'assalto
all'università
e costringono
i professori
e gli studenti
a rinunciare
a qualunque privilegio
che il re
gli abbia mai concesso
d'ora in poi
l'università di Cambridge
ubbidirà
al comune
di Cambridge
basta privilegi
nel Norfolk
il capo
dei ribelli
è un tintore
John Lister
e nel Norfolk
nel nord
dell'Inghilterra
i ribelli
vanno di villaggio
in villaggio
e vanno a casa
dei nobili
dei cavalieri
dicendogli
anche voi
dovete stare con noi
perché la nostra causa
è quella giusta
vero che venite
con noi
anche voi
e i nobili cavalieri
presi uno
per uno
seguono la folla
dei ribelli
c'è soltanto
un cavaliere
che protesta
Sir Robert de Salle
era il cavaliere
più famoso
d'Inghilterra
era l'uomo
più alto
d'Inghilterra
più forzuto
e considerato
il più coraggioso
d'Inghilterra
un grande guerriero
era uno che non era
neanche nato nobile
era un plebeo
che il re
aveva fatto cavaliere
per il suo enorme valore
in battaglia
anche Sir Robert de Salle
viene costretto
a seguire i ribelli
ma mentre gli altri cavalieri
stanno ben zitti
Sir Robert de Salle
non sta zitto
e sostiene
che non è giusto
quello che stanno facendo
e che finirà malissimo
e che dovrebbero vergognarsi
finalmente
uno dei contadini
non ne può più
è un suo servo
e un suo servo
prende un bastone
gli dà una botta in testa
e lo ammazza
e il cronista commenta
un cavaliere
che avrebbe messo in fuga
mille di quei rustici
se se lo fossero trovati davanti
su un campo di battaglia
e invece lì
in quel contesto
l'hanno ammazzato come niente
sono forti
sono tanti
però poco dopo
i ribelli del Norfolk
mandano una delegazione
al re
con le loro richieste
e questa delegazione
si imbatte
nel vescovo di Norwich
il vescovo di Norwich
con alcuni
dei suoi cavalieri
sulla strada
vede arrivare
questa delegazione
dei ribelli
il vescovo di Norwich
Henry Spencer
è un giovanotto
che preferisce
la guerra
e la caccia
al dire messa
come non è raro
tra i vescovi dell'epoca
è uno bellicoso
e manesco
vede arrivare
questa delegazione
dei ribelli
gli chiede chi sono
quando ha capito
chi sono
li fa acchiappare
e li fa decapitare
tutti quanti
dopodiché
raduna gli uomini
d'arma
e i nobili
del circondario
e marcia
verso il grosso
dei ribelli
del Norfolk
li affronta
i ribelli
vedendoli arrivare
si sono trincerati
dietro un fossato
hanno fatto
una specie di barricata
ma qui
come sempre
in queste storie
che vi racconto
si vede che
al momento
in cui la parola
è alle armi
un nobile signore
sbaraglia
come niente
venti contadini
non c'è niente da fare
se sei a cavallo
armato
e soprattutto
sai combattere
non c'è storia
il vescovo
carica i ribelli
cento volte più numerosi
li sbaraglia
li mette in rotta
cattura il capo
John Lister
lo processa
è condannato
a essere trascinato
e impiccato
trascinato
vuol dire
che per portarlo
al patibolo
lo legano
alla coda del cavallo
per i piedi
e lo portano
al patibolo così
rimbalzando
dietro al cavallo
dopodiché
siamo nel medioevo
è una società
piena di sorprese
dopo tutto questo
il vescovo
confessa
John Lister
lo assolve
e poi
lo accompagna
al patibolo
reggendogli la testa
lui è legato
per i piedi
al cavallo
naturalmente
reggendogli la testa
perché non si rompa
la testa
sulle pietre
dopodiché
al patibolo
viene impiccato
torniamo a Londra
a Londra
il re
va in pellegrinaggio
all'abbazia
di Westminster
prega
nell'abbazia
la Madonna
a Westminster
c'è un'immagine
miracolosa
della Madonna
di cui il re
è particolarmente
devoto
parla a lungo
con l'eremita
che vive
murato
nei sotterranei
della cattedrale
perché lì
c'è un'eremita
il quale
volontariamente
per allontanarsi
dal mondo
ha chiesto
di essere
murato
nella cattedrale
c'è uno sportellino
gli danno da bere
da mangiare
ovviamente
eccetera
il re scende
e si intrattiene
a lungo
con l'eremita
e poi
fa proclamare
che adesso è lui
che vuole parlare
con i ribelli
noi non sappiamo
in realtà
se abbia un piano
il re
o se sono i ribelli
che hanno insistito
che vogliono parlargli
ancora
quello che è certo
è che si trovano
di nuovo
fuori Londra
in un altro
di questi grandi prati
che ci sono fuori Londra
a Smithfield
e lì di nuovo
c'è la folla
dei ribelli
e il re
con pochi cavalieri
e con il sindaco
di Londra
e Watt Tyler
di nuovo
esce dalla folla
e viene incontro
al re a cavallo
qui abbiamo descrizioni
dettagliatissime
di quello che succede
Watt Tyler
è a cavallo
anche se lui
è un fabbricante
di tegole
non è mai andato a cavallo
in vita sua
però è a cavallo
perché i suoi
centomila
no sono diminuiti
nel frattempo
sono già molto diminuiti
tanta gente è tornata a casa
i suoi lì
a piedi lo vedono
sta andando
dal re
il nostro Watt
Watt Tyler
va dal re
smonta da cavallo
davanti al re
ha la spada in mano
mette un ginocchio
a terra
ha comunque
la consapevolezza
che di fronte al re
ci sono certe regole
da rispettare
però poveretto
ha una vaga idea
delle regole
da rispettare
ma molto vaga
dopo essersi inginocchiato
si rialza
e stringe vigorosamente
la mano al re
dicendogli
fratello
stai sereno
perché
vedi quanti uomini
ci sono
e ne stanno arrivando
altri
il cronista dice
si tranquillo
e gioioso
sono leggermente
interpretato
ma insomma
vedi quanti uomini
quanti siamo
e ne arriveranno altri
e saremo
buoni compagni
e il re
gli dice
ma perché
non tornate
al vostro paese
e Watt Tyler
risponde
che non hanno ancora
ottenuto
tutto quello
che vogliono
e il re
dice va bene
vi darò
quello che volete
cosa volete
ancora
e Watt Tyler
dice
intanto hanno fatto
un salto di qualità
la servitura
è stata abolita
benissimo
ma non ci basta più
non si devono
fare nuove leggi
sempre la solita storia
no?
le leggi
del tempo
dei miei padri
a me vanno bene
quelle nuove
sono sempre fregature
non le voglio
vivremo
secondo le vecchie
leggi
del tempo
dei nostri padri
e nessun lord
deve più avere
una signoria
ma la terra
deve essere divisa
fra tutti
il vecchio comunista
John Ball
nel frattempo
ha lavorato
chiaramente
in mezzo ai ribelli
solo il re
deve avere
delle grandi proprietà
nessun altro
e il clero
il clero
deve essere mantenuto
ma tutte le terre
dei monasteri
devono essere distribuite
fra il popolo
e ci deve essere
un solo vescovo
in Inghilterra
perché così tanti
che costano cari
a mantenerli
e poi naturalmente
ripetiamolo
non ci deve mai più
essere un servo
in Inghilterra
il re promette tutto
a questo punto
giugno
fa un caldo mortale
Wattailer
chiede da bere
gli portano
una brocca d'acqua
prima di tutto
la brocca d'acqua
non è per bere
per sciacquarsi la bocca
nessuno beve acqua
se può farne a meno
oltretutto
l'acqua
fa malissimo
è acqua di pozzo
di fiume
ma la brocca d'acqua
serve per sciacquarsi la bocca
Wattailer
è un fabbricante
di tegole
le buone maniere
non le conosce
si sciacqua la bocca
e sputa abbondantemente
in presenza del re
e poi
e adesso per bere
gli portano
un boccale di birra
quella sì
e tra canna
il boccale di birra
e risale a cavallo
e intanto
uno dei valletti
del re
dice ad alta voce
ma guarda
come si comporta
quello lì
è il più gran
furfante
del Kent
Watt lo sente
e gli dice
vieni un po' qui
il valletto
non andrebbe
ma i nobili lordi
del seguito del re
terrorizzati
lo spingono avanti
il valletto
si fa sotto
Wattailer
ha con sé
un compagno a cavallo
che porta
lo stendardo di San Giorgio
gli dice
scendi
e taglia la testa
a questo traditore
il valletto
a questo punto
non può fare altro
ribatte
non è giusto
non sono un traditore
non me lo sono meritato
ho detto solo la verità
a questo punto
Wattailer
che ha sempre la spada
in pugno
alza la spada
per colpire il valletto
è più di quello
che si può tollerare
in presenza del re
si possono tollerare
tante cose
ma le buone maniere
sono la più importante
il sindaco di Londra
si fa
trova il coraggio
di affrontare Watt
fermarlo
e dirgli
ma si fa questo
in presenza del re
a questo punto
Watt tira una botta
con la spada
al sindaco di Londra
ma il sindaco di Londra
sotto il vestito
ha la corazza
non si fa niente
tira fuori lui
la spada
e colpisce Watt
lo colpisce due volte
al collo
Watt fa in tempo
a risalire a cavallo
poi un altro
lo raggiunge
lo colpisce di nuovo
Watt cade a terra
mezzo morto
la folla dei suoi
e laggiù
50 metri più indietro
non vedono niente
dov'è Watt?
non lo vedo più
qualcuno dice
si vede che si è inginocchiato
perché il re
lo sta facendo cavaliere
qualcun altro dice
no no
sta succedendo qualcosa
qualcuno comincia
a tirare con l'arco
a questo punto
il re fa la sua parte
il re quattordicenne
sprona il cavallo
va davanti ai ribelli
e gli dice
sempre il vecchio discorso
che si fa
quando si vuol confondere la gente
il vostro capo
era un traditore
io sono il vostro capo
io sono il vostro re
dovete fidarvi di me
d'ora in poi seguitemi
e io sarò il vostro capo
mentre il re
parla con i ribelli
confusi e perplessi
i nobili signori
sono tutti nel panico
l'unico che tiene la testa
sulle spalle
è il sindaco di Londra
il sindaco galoppa a Londra
che è a cinque minuti
entra a Londra
e comincia a far uscire
la popolazione di Londra
in armi
inquadrata in armi
Londra è un comune
la sua popolazione
è abituata
a fare la guerra
inquadrata
a difesa della città
ognuno al suo posto
il sindaco dice
il re è in pericolo
e a questo punto
la milizia di Londra
esce armata
e in pochi minuti
è a Smithfield
dove i ribelli
sono ancora lì
confusi
senza capo
con il re che gli sta
gli sta raccontando
tutte le sue belle cose
e la milizia di Londra
arriva molto numerosa
molti ribelli
sono già tornati a casa
ripetiamolo
e comincia
a circondare
i ribelli
e a questo punto
di colpo
non capiscono più niente
si spaventano
e cominciano
a buttare le armi
i bastoni
gli archi
e cominciano
a inginocchiarsi
e implorare
pietà
a questo punto
c'è una sceneggiata
i nobili signori
del seguito del re
che fino a quel momento
non hanno mosso un dito
ripreso coraggio
vanno dal re
e gli dicono
adesso gliela facciamo vedere
a questi villani
che hanno osato sfidare
il re
e i nobili
dacci il permesso
di decapitarne
cento o duecento
il re dice di no
non sono tutti colpevoli
molti non sanno
cosa stanno facendo
si sono uniti alla folla
per paura
non lo facciamo
il re da ordine
ai ribelli
ridatemi le vostre insegne
di San Giorgio
e i ribelli
cedono le insegne
il re ordina
ridatemi le lettere patenti
le pergamene
tutto quello che ho concesso
tutto quello che c'è ancora
viene ridato
e stracciato
sotto i loro occhi
dopodiché
il re ordina a tutti
di tornare a casa
vieta a qualunque forestiero
di tornare a Londra
e se ne torna a Londra
col suo seguito
mentre i ribelli
si disperdono
nota un cronista
ma molti vennero uccisi
dopo che il re
se ne era andato
il sindaco di Londra
a questo punto
ha ancora un lavoro da fare
a cercare
Watt Tyler
che non è mica morto
è stato colpito
da diversi colpi
di spada
dov'è
dove non è
lo vanno a cercare
lo hanno portato
in ospedale
naturalmente
c'è un ospedale
lì vicino
è lì
a letto
nella camera
del direttore
dell'ospedale
il sindaco di Londra
va
lo trascina fuori
mezzo morto
lo decapita
sul posto
e la testa
di Watt
viene portata
in trionfo
a Londra
a questo punto
il re ordina
il sindaco di Londra
di mettersi un elmo
in testa
il sindaco di Londra
che è un mercante
i londinesi
sono tutti mercanti
naturalmente
brava gente
che traffica
che lavora
metti un elmo in testa
dice sì
perché ti devo ricompensare
per quello che hai fatto
ti voglio armare
cavaliere
il sindaco di Londra
che è un bravo mercante
è sgomento
perché fare il cavaliere
non è esattamente
una prospettiva
che gli fosse mai venuta in mente
e inoltre
per fare il cavaliere
ci vogliono un sacco di soldi
per mantenere
il tenore di vita adeguato
il re insiste
a tutti i costi
lo arma cavaliere
dopodiché
gli regala però
anche proprietà terriere
a sufficienza
per poter mantenere
il suo nuovo rango
e a questo punto
è davvero finita
e comincia la repressione
perché ci sono ancora
dei ribelli in giro
per le contee
ci sono gruppi di ribelli
che scrivono al re
dicendo
ma e le promesse
vogliamo che siano mantenute
uno dei cronisti
racconta
se l'ha inventato lui
ma è per capire
in che modo
questi monaci vedono
la conclusione
della faccenda
uno dei cronisti
racconta
che il re
gli avrebbe risposto
villani siete
e villani resterete
rimarrete in servitù
non come prima
ma molto più dura
i ribelli
vengono dispersi
tutti quelli
che vengono in ginocchio
a chiedere pietà
vengono risparmiati
a patto
di denunciare
i capi
e a questo punto
in tutto il regno
mentre la gente
è tornata a casa
cominciano
i processi
e il paese
tacque
alla vista
dei giudici
e il popolo
tremò
secondo un cronista
si arriva a qualcosa
come 1500
esecuzioni
all'inizio
li decapitano
per tradimento
poi
anche perché
si fa più in fretta
non devi stare
a tirare sulla forca
poi in realtà
decidono che non va bene
perché comunque
la decapitazione
è una pena
troppo prestigiosa
e questa gente
non lo merita
e quindi
si comincia
a impiccare
John Ball
viene arrestato
trascinato
impiccato
e squartato
al monastero
di St Albans
e la sua testa
viene esposta
con quella
di Watt Tyler
sul ponte di Londra
il monaco
di St Albans
che racconta
cosa è successo
nel suo paese
racconta
che lì
sono stati
decapitati
15 capi
dei ribelli
servi del monastero
che erano insorti
e uno di loro
racconta
il cronista
prima di morire
fece il seguente
discorso
questa è una cosa
abbastanza
sbalorditiva
perché il cronista
è lo stesso
che esulta
perché
i villani
sono stati
stroncati
e resteranno
servi come prima
anzi
peggio di prima
però poi dice
questo loro capo
quando morì
disse
con cittadini
e il cronista
nota
perché si erano
messi in testa
di farsi chiamare
così
cittadini
Cives
scrive lui
che un po'
di libertà
ha risollevato
da lunghi anni
di oppressione
tenete duro
finché potete
se dovrò morire
per la causa
della libertà
sarò contento
di finire
la mia vita
da martire
ora il punto
non è
avrà davvero
detto queste belle parole
questo non lo sa
nessuno
la cosa straordinaria
è che un monaco
ostile
gli attribuisce
questo discorso
è lo stesso monaco
che in altri posti
della cronica
dice sì
perché appunto
volevano farsi
chiamare cittadini
e insistevano
che d'ora in poi
nel regno
ci dovevano essere
soltanto il re
e i comuni
e questa parola
comuni
gli sembrava
la più bella parola
del mondo
altre parole
questo è un nemico
di classe
che capisce
perfettamente
cosa pensano
cosa vogliono
questa gente
non c'è nessuna finzione
questi hanno degli ideali
dei valori
lottano per quello
peccato che noi
siamo i padroni
e invece li vogliamo
tenere sotto
e quindi
meno male
che è andata così
dopodiché
però naturalmente
appunto siamo
nel medioevo
qualche mese
di processi
ed esecuzioni
poi poi basta
è ora di farla finita
il primo parlamento
che si riunisce
a Westminster
a settembre
decreta il colpo
di spugna
chiunque non è stato
ancora impiccato
basta
grazie per tutti
quelli che sono rimasti
non se ne parla più
e naturalmente
la grande carta
di liberazione
che dichiarava
che non ci sarà
più un servo
in tutta l'Inghilterra
fu abolita
annullata
e dichiarata
senza valore
nel Parlamento
e non ci sarà
mai più
una rivolta
così
in Inghilterra
però ci sarà
una rivoluzione
in Inghilterra
come molti di voi
sanno
tempo dopo
molto tempo dopo
sono cambiate
un po' di cose
ma certe altre cose
sono rimaste uguali
c'è un re
che nel 600
non è più
un 14enne
spaventato
e ha le idee
molto chiare
e vuole diventare
un sovrano
assoluto
e non vuole più
dover
come dire
chiedere il permesso
al Parlamento
per poter
imporre nuove tasse
e la rivoluzione inglese
lo sapete
negli anni 40
del 600
e c'è un Parlamento
dove la Camera
dei Comuni
dichiara
che il re
non ha il diritto
di imporre nuove tasse
e sciogliere il Parlamento
a suo piacimento
e il re Carlo I
scioglie il Parlamento
e il Parlamento
raduna un esercito
e a nome
dei Comuni
di Inghilterra
dichiara guerra
al re
e lo sconfigge
e lo arresta
e lo processa
per alto tradimento
il re
per aver tradito
i Comuni
di Inghilterra
e gli taglia
la testa
perché la decapitazione
è quello
che tocca
ai traditori
grazie